the san francisco 49ers draft class
there it is the most significant pick
number three overall trey lance the guy
they traded up
to get jed york team ceo appearing on
the 49ers talk podcast courtesy of nbc
sports bay area
addressing the quarterback situation now
they have both jimmy garoppolo and trey
lance
you know if if we are in a situation
where
jimmy goes out and takes us to the super
bowl again
and and has an mvp caliber season and
does it again
there are worse dilemmas to be in and
jimmy certainly has the ability to do
that
i think kyle's talked about that all
along and knowing it's the most
important position in sports
and it's great to have a guy that you
you do believe in that that has gotten
you to a super bowl
so you don't have to put the weight of
the world on a rookie
whoever it was we were going to choose
now that we know that trey is here
you don't have to put the weight of the
world on that kid's shoulders
and he can grow into that position for
us if you invest
25 or 50 million dollars into your
rookie to get them ready
then i mean to me like we're investing
in the long-term future of our team
you know this sunday he turns 21 if he
doesn't play until he's 23
you know but he's got a 15 plus year
career i mean
you know there were rumors about a guy
and obviously kyle talked about trading
for aaron
how long did aaron sit two three years
before he played
and and again i want to make sure that
we do everything that we can to make
sure that that position is the best it
can possibly be in the nfl
we're trying to build out a team that
can compete for a championship today and
can compete for a championship over a
period of time
and we'll make the best decisions not
where well
you know you trade it up and like this
is a third pick and he has to play
right now well i mean if if he's the
best player then then he would play
and if he's not ready to do it yet we're
not going to put that on his shoulders
i i really don't know what the 49ers are
thinking they're just
they're trying to create a market for
jimmy garoppolo as best they can
and if they would get an offer that they
like for garoppolo all this talk about
well we'll keep garoppolo it'll be a 50
million dollar investment getting our
guy ready we'll pay jimmy 50 moon over
the next two years
while trey lance quietly develops and
hey maybe he'll sit three years like
aaron rodgers completely different
situation
rogers was the guy who fell to the
packers thank you the packers realized
here's an opportunity for insurance
against this wishy-washy brett favre
before retire right or whatever right
yeah not we're gonna give
up three first-round picks right and a
third round pick
for one guy that may or may not be our
quarterback
we'll see maybe jimmy g and they're
playing with fire here because
you know it's not like a 10 chance jimmy
garoppolo is able to play the full
season
2019 he played the full season 2018
didn't 2020 didn't maybe 2021
he will and maybe the team does well
enough
that you tie your own hands for 2022
even though garoppolo doesn't suddenly
morph into patrick mahomes
and maybe garoppolo in the super bowl
once again fails to hit a guy who's wide
open on the championship throw
so they are playing with fire here as
they try to get something for garoppolo
and they can pivot away from that any
time they want
and they can ultimately pay garoppolo 25
million this year
for whatever reason they want they got
the money they got the cap space if they
want to do it god bless you but
it just chris i have a hard time
picking up on a cohesive thread of a
strategy
as to what the 49ers are doing in a way
that makes me believe that it all makes
sense
and that it's a strategy that is one
other team should be emulating
uh i i'm with you there mike i i it does
seem you know fly by the seat of the
pants type of like strategy right now
there's no
doubt about it yeah i don't know what
what the the messages they're trying to
get out with the jimmy g situation
you're right i mean
listen that's the first thing i think of
are they trying to like make these
strong comments
to drive up or drum up some trade
interest
do that or is it really just about hey
like trey lance is a raw guy and we're
going to let jimmy g play this year and
you know trey lance will just come in in
some taste some hill type situations
and we'll get him some reps like that
where he can run the ball and maybe
throw a ball here or there
i don't know that's that's where and
you're right i mean
they are playing with with with fire you
know i think
the the the first thing is that this
jumps out to me like you mentioned it
the scenarios are different and like it
was brett favre
so brett favre is a little harder to
beat out
you know than let's just say jimmy g
alright so there's that angle first off
like
i think if a year goes by two years go
by and we're still not starting trey
lance
i would be in the camp of like what's
going on why can't he
beat the number 20th quarterback in
football out to be the starting
quarterback
that wouldn't be a good look and you
know two
it's just not a good look ever to have
so many
resources allocated to one spot
that's where you play with fire like one
like you mentioned like hey 2021
hey the jimmy g plays they do well they
go on a playoff run they have a playoff
caliber football team
you know what they get to the nfc
championship game
yeah you bring them back and you just go
well i mean we got 50 like you said over
50 million dollars and three first round
picks and
we they traded a pick to get jimmy
garoppolo all these assets have been
traded for the quarterback position
and we're basically wasting some of it
on the sidelines
let alone the last part of this mic to
me just again that does not make sense
and you've heard me say this
like this kid needs to play football
he's got to play he can't be sitting on
a bench for two years and doing that
that's the biggest issue in his game
and quarterback as you've heard me say
before practice great
great practice is great but until aaron
donald's coming off the edge
and they're disguising and people are
yelling and all that yeah it's great
it's a nice practice whoopidy do
it's just a different game you can't
emulate what goes on in the field so
there's
there's a lot of things here that i
think are a little bit i don't know
confusing
with the 49er situation i almost feel
like they have taken bits and pieces of
different quarterback strategies that
they've seen other teams employ over the
years
and they've tried to create a
frankenstein monster out of it of all
these different
well you know it is maybe like aaron
rodgers because maybe this will piss him
off enough sorry
manchester that that jimmy g will have a
great year this year maybe he'll be
really focused that was one of the first
things kyle shanahan said
right at the press conference they had
after they made the trade he's upset
good be upset go out there and play well
make us regret it and so i guess what
you could say is
if on one hand jed york is going to
claim they're making a 50 million dollar
investment via the
compensation to be paid to jimmy
garoppolo over the next two years in
order to let trey lance develop
you could also justify this by saying we
made an investment of three first-round
picks and a third round pick to get
jimmy g
to finally be the guy that we think he
can be and it worked
and he got pissed off and he played
great so now he's our starter
and what are we gonna do with trey lance
well we made that investment to get the
most out of jimmy g but i just
i there's too many contradictions
there's too many inconsistencies that's
the problem with this 49ers strategy
under pressure it doesn't hold up i'd
love to cross-examine
john lynch kyle shanahan and jed york
for a couple hours each
because i would get them fairly quickly
twisted in knots
and use their words against them and
demonstrate that at the core of this
chris
there really isn't a strong thread
of solid clear logic and i frankly think
that this is a reaction to the fact that
they blew it with patrick mahomes
they did and they blew up with tom brady
they did the two quarterbacks that they
got to watch play
in super bowl 55 they could have had
each one and they didn't
and this is their holy crap we got to do
something
to rectify for ourselves the fact that
we blew it on my homes and we blew it on
brady because brady wanted to play for
them and they said
no thanks we're good with jimmy g i i i
don't disagree with that it
i i it does seem like a little bit of a
overreaction
to you know those events that happened
that certainly you know affected their
football team
there's no doubt about that uh it's
yeah it this is a this is like we talked
about it's a career defining
defining moment for shanahan and lynch i
mean they're going to be attached to
trey lance
forever as we go forward here and yes it
you know
it's a lot of it doesn't make sense to
me you know i i am one that's always
said you don't trade up to spot number
three for an unproven commodity that
might not
play for a year or two and give up three
first rounds for that type of player
that i don't understand either and the
other thing too just to bring it back to
like jimmy g
a little bit and this is where i'm a
little
like in the boat of i think them
trading jimmy g now at this point
to me is almost gone it's sailed and
gone unless there's like some
training camp injury you know a la teddy
bridgewater style with the minnesota
vikings back in the day in the sam
bradford trade
because really who else out there right
now is gonna really want jimmy g
i mean maybe the houston texans maybe i
i don't know but they did just draft
davis mill they got tyrod taylor there
as well
i don't think there's gonna be any trade
interest for him now so
the way they played this and of course
with the quarterback they ultimately
ended up drafting
i i mean it seems like they're i think
they're stuck with jimmy g
for this year for now it's entirely
possible that jimmy g
has made it clear to the 49ers via don
yee that under no circumstances will he
take less than what he's due to make
this year so
you can forget about trying to trip
that's very true too restructured
contract
and if you want to hold me through
pre-season
training camp up until labor day weekend
and cut me then
and you think i'm not going to land
somewhere else and i don't have
guaranteed money i don't care i've made
100 million
off of you guys already i'll i'll
i'll play that game you want to play
that game let's play that game so
the other side of this and the last
point i'll make before we take a break
um
i i recommend
that kyle and john lynch really
you know keep by the nft of the
original master recordings of that
podcast with jed york you may need it
later when jed york is asking you a
bunch of tough questions about why you
guys did what you did because jed york's
on the record he's all in he's on board
now here's the reality if things go to
hell on roller skates over the next
couple of years for the 49ers and this
ends up being a disaster
jed york's not the one that's getting
fired for it as jed york said a few
years ago you can't fire the owner
but you can't fire everybody else and
there will be accountability and that's
what makes this riskier
than than i think most people realize
chris if this
fails this is on kyle and this is on
john lynch
yeah i mean yes there's no doubt you
know i think when you take into
all the you know surrounding events
you know the jimmy g situation how
that's handled everything like that
you know to trade up to number three yes
a somewhat controversial pick
you know also the angle of
did you did you really have to trade up
to number three to get trey lance
you know and i get again yeah i think
you could say you know
i don't think they did really honestly
just just looking at it looking at the
board
it was a trade that was made very early
on in the process
and maybe that it was made with jumping
into conclusions of what you thought
teams might do or anything like that but
at a base level right now from what i
know around the nfl and things i've said
here and everything like that
i mean if the 49ers didn't take trey
lance at three
there's a hard nobody knows exactly
where he would have landed i know he
would have gone on the first round
but i don't think it was in any danger
of anybody in the top ten taking him and
that's also going to be something that
they're going to be
kind of held under a microscope about
too as we go forward
and i'd love to know where that urgency
came from when you get
shanahan lynch and york in a room who's
the one
that finally blinked and said damn it
we blew it with mahomes we blew it with
brady we're not gonna blow it this time
do the effing trade now
and uh uh i i i don't know
i don't know but somebody pulled the pin
on that grenade
and uh it's going to take a lot longer
than 10 seconds for it to blow up and it
may never
blow up but when it does when it does
jed york is going to be well out of
shrapnel range for it so we'll see how
that plays out over the next few years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports